en el foco de atención el contagio de
kobe 19 del presidente de donald trump
que aumenta las apuestas en la noche del
único debate vicepresidencial previo a
las elecciones del 3 de noviembre de un
lado del escenario en sound life city
estará la candidata demócrata a la
vicepresidencia kamala harris del otro
el vicepresidente mike pence esta vez
separados por un escudo de plexiglás y
una distancia de más de 37 metros como
medidas de bioseguridad adicionales la
compañera de fórmula del demócrata joe
biden es la primera mujer afroamericana
candidata a la vicepresidencia de un
gran partido go live your life votan
como si sus vidas dependiera de ello
porque así es desde atrás
la progresista kamala harris de 55 años
quien llegó a washington como senadora
de california en 2017 es conocida como
una prominente interrogadora gracias a
su trayectoria como abogada con un gran
talento para el combate verbal se
enfrentará a un aguerrido comunicador
mike pence de 61 años cristiano
evangélico conservador del medioeste
fiel a donald trump
me encanta trabajar con un presidente
que saca a relucir sentimientos tan
fuertes de apoyo en todo eeuu
los interrogantes en torno a la salud
del mandatario suman presión sobre el
vicepresidente que busca la religión
pensó intentará tranquilizar a un
electorado nervioso demostrando que está
listo para asumir el cargo si la
situación lo requiere a la vez que
defenderá la respuesta a la pandemia de
la administración trump encabezada por
pence de los posibles ataques de harris
se espera que el cara a cara
vicepresidencial sea menos agresivo que
el primer debate presidencial de hace
una semana estuvo marcado por los
ataques personales una cosa será
notablemente diferente todos los
asistentes y la audiencia deberán portar
mascarillas